each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available hi good afternoon
everybody um let's get
started um my name is rul Mahajan I work
here at moft research and with great
pleasure along with Nikolai who's also
my colleague at Microsoft research
welcome you to the network verification
session um actually to be to be fair I
think like we are Nikolai and I just
puppets this this session is the
brainchild of George here you'll hear
second and he's like the real puppet
master here but uh getting um getting to
the the topic of the session is
basically Network verification and the
motivation is simple for anybody who
runs networks that are more than two
routers would know how messy today's
networks are are and not to even talk
about how complex networks at large
companies like ours at Microsoft are to
the extent that even it's hard to reason
about even something that's made up of
like three routers I would say um and I
think there's a theme of research that
has been going on for the last few years
trying to essentially make sense of it
the focus of this session is essentially
to say what inspiration we can draw from
the fields of hardware and software
verification to make our networks more
understandable uh correct and
verifiable and we have essentially
um we have an excellent line of speakers
who've done a lot of work in this
particular area and this is what each of
the speakers is going to focus on we'll
start with Shard who is well known in
the field of Eda and design Automation
and Analysis and we'll move on to George
Jeff and Nate and we'll introduce the
speakers uh as they kind of go along um
the the whole purpose would be to
essentially draw parallels and see what
we can learn from Eda as applied to you
know Network design Automation and the
merger here is somewhat natural for
those of you who have not followed
design automation is that a lot of the
design automation tools have
verification at at the heart of them so
in the sense you can think about
verification being a precursor to design
automation as as well so we'll kind of
Follow That Journey along with these
speakers who've seen this happen in some
way or the other so um then without Much
Ado I'd like to welcome Sharad as a
first Speaker uh for those of you who
don't know sh he's actually very famous
in this community but he received his um
bachelor's degree at Indian Institute of
Technology Delhi kind of proudly say
that I went to the same College um and
right now he's a professor at Princeton
University and sure has done some
foundational work on propositional
satisfiability that's being used in a
lot of industrial uh design automation
tools and he's B won a bunch of awards
for his papers like especially 50-year
most sided papers or 10e retrospec is
those are the kinds of awards that the
computer science Community really values
and Sh has not not just one one but many
others and today he's going to talk
about what lessons we the networking
community and learn from what he's seen
from
Eda welcome thank
you let me just get my slide
up
okay while this is going up uh thanks a
lot for this uh int introduction this
invitation um it's really a pleasure
being here and getting to learn from a
very diverse Community here so as uh rul
pointed out my background is in
electronic design Automation and uh I
have very little background in in
networking uh so what I'll what I'll be
talking about is you know my
perspectives from from my background
electronic design automation uh coming
into Network verification and I'll talk
a little bit about the work that I've
done there but mostly what I'll be
talking about is you know Lessons
Learned uh at least in terms of you know
how the whole field has evolved in terms
of electronic design Automation and what
lessons uh they might be for possibly uh
Network design automation if that were
to exist as an entity of its own so uh
if you look at
electronic okay I okay so it's a little
slow so if you look at electronic design
automation this is a very well
established industry it's a $4 billion
annual annual revenue industry which
then feeds into a $350 billion
semiconductor industry which then feeds
into a$3 trillion uh electronics
Industry so essentially everything at
the heart of this is enabled by chips
that then get designed by these tools
and uh but if you look at these tools
these tools really uh it's it's not just
these tools that are at the heart of Eda
but really it's a whole design
methodology that these tools are part of
and that's one of the key messages that
I want to make sure that goes through
that is you know there's a there's a
very keen interplay between design
Automation and design methodology and we
shouldn't be looking at one without the
other uh so in particular I'll start off
with a few components of
this okay uh so this is a little slow
I'm I'm just going to go to the podium
here it'll be
faster so so then I can't see the screen
so I have to come back um so one of the
key components of this interplay is that
U these design tools uh uh impose a
certain uh discipline in the design
methodology and in particular what I
mean by this uh discipline is that you
have a disciplined restriction of
possible choices so when we do design we
really have a whole uh you know pallet
in front of us in terms of the things we
can do what design discipline does for
us is it it forces us us to make certain
restrictions in what we are allowed to
do what we are not allowed to do and
this happens in in in multiple areas not
just electronic design and I'll give a
sort of classic example of
this actually would it be possible to
switch this this
is not I I can get
one
okay
yeah I'm not sure where it plugs in
though oh I suspect it's got to do more
with the fact that this is boxed up
rather than the pointer itself okay so I
guess it's a distance issue so I need to
be closer here okay so let let me give a
sort of classic example of design
discipline and uh so if you look at
digital design it's almost universally
done using what's called a synchronous
design methodology and what that means
is that U we uh restrict ourselves to a
style of design where all the state
changes all the memory elements that are
storing State they all change
synchronously with respect to the clock
today we take it for granted but we
don't have to do it this way this is not
the only way we can do design uh but
what this does for us is it ensures that
all state changes at the same time so
the state of time uh t+1 is some
function this function f which is
computed by this piece of combinational
logic of the state at time T and the
external inputs so you know if you're
thinking about Network design uh
methodology and and network design
automation I think then we have to look
at so what are the elements of design
discipline that would go into this that
would you know help that process so I'm
going to be asking a lot of question
questions and not providing too many
answers largely because I don't know the
answers I'm hoping that they'll come out
of conversations that result at the end
of this so the second element uh that we
have uh that uh shows this interplay
between design Automation and design
methodology is that you know any design
process goes through a flow of design
refinement so in the hardware case what
you have is you start off with a design
that's referred to as a behavioral
design and really at this level all
you're doing is you're describing
functions that modify State update State
this then goes through uh some synthesis
converts which which converts it into a
logic design which is Gates and the
interconnections which then goes to some
further steps into some physical and
mass design which really then at that
point is referring to objects which have
coordinates 2D and 3D
coordinates and at the in so what's
going on during this process is there's
a whole bunch of design tools that are
helping uh you go through these steps
and these tools match the level of
abstraction so each of these tools uh
works on a given level of abstraction
understands that pretty well and that's
where all the algorithms are built in
all the analysis techniques are built in
so again the question the corresponding
question is that you know if you're
going to look at Network design uh what
are the design flows and abstractions
and people have to sort of agree on
these these have to be agreed on uh by
the community and so is it a is it is it
a more ad hoc process or is it a more
structured process that looks like this
because this is really where what we
need to look will need it to look like
uh if we hope to do uh any serious
automation
there so the Third uh component that I'm
going to talk about here is this uh
design process which is referred to as
designed by composition and this is
something that we do in software all the
time and we're doing it in Hardware
that's the only way we can we can build
large complex systems and really what
this means is that with standardized
interfaces such as cell libraries memory
interfaces bus interfaces we can compose
large designs by just plugging in
different alternatives for smaller
components okay so it's a fairly
standard concept you understand this uh
while it may seem trivial but uh we
absolutely for for a systematic design
methodology with automation we will need
standardized interfaces for design by
composition and the question is what are
these for Network design
today so um as we look at this interplay
between uh design methodology and and
design tools so the the first thing that
I immediately sort of I realized was
that in in Hardware design we really
didn't have a choice in terms of design
automation uh so here's the obligatory
morla slide you know the complexity
pretty much forced us to have automation
there's no way we could have had uh the
design process go without automation
here uh and in fact in this area we we
sort of have had this wonderful
bootstrapping Arrangement where we've
used uh today's computers to design
tomorrow's computers but this complexity
is not limited to processor chips if we
just look at the whole range of uh
computer of of uh digital electronics
that we design uh even you know
non-pressor designs have very
significant complexity of the of
hundreds of millions of
gates um now if I take this particular
analogy and apply it to network design
uh I I really don't think that the
growing Network complexity is going to
be the driver for Network design
Automation and the reason for that is we
already have large complex networks and
we don't have Network design automation
so we've done pretty well in terms of
network design uh at least in terms of
making these products selling them and
so
on so this this I I don't believe is is
going to be the driver this complexity
is not going to be The Driver uh this in
that sense this is more like the
software industry where again software
is complex uh but in terms of Automation
and methodology you know there's really
not something that's very standard that
people all systematically follow um but
if you then narrow down automation to
just the verification part um and again
in the hardware case this became very
necessary and it's necessary because of
the high cost of failure so in
particular the thing that really Pro
demands this is the need for first
silicon success that is the first chip
that that gets fabricated out has to
work or or there's a high economic
incentive to make it work it doesn't
always work but there's a high economic
incentive to make it work so we
essentially have to have working parts
right off the fabrication line and the
reason for that is the mass costs are
very high so if the part doesn't work
you have to go back and redo the masks
you're going to pay in in excess of tens
of millions of dollars to do a fresh set
of
masks uh but uh more important is is the
cost of product product recall so for
those of you have are old enough to
remember this uh so in 1994 there was a
famous Intel Pentium FIV bug and uh
these are the two arguments that
resulted in an incorrect result in uh
flooring Point Division and this was
very expensive uh Intel had to do a
product recall cost was was roughly half
a billion dollars now this one incident
I credit as being the single largest
reason why we have formal verification
today in both the hardware and the
software communities because this cost
essentially prompted a big push in the
industry to have formal techniques where
you could have proofs of correctness in
advance of uh designs being being ready
and
shipped so um I so so if I look at the
corresponding questions and say okay so
in network verification this I believe
is is already true that is the downtime
costs and security breach costs uh are I
think very compelling for Network
verification so I don't even list this
as a question I just list this as a
statement I believe that this is a
significant driver sufficient driver uh
for Automation in network
verification um but if you look at a
broader uh Network design automation uh
let's go back to Eda and uh see that in
addition to it being necessary it
actually has been very valuable it's
provided uh many uh uh many significant
things that have made it uh key part of
what we do today so of course it's given
us design scalability the ability to
handle larger designs it in addition has
given us design diversity because we can
automate and have a methodology that
lets us design in a fairly systematic
way we get we can build a build a big
range of components we're not just
building processors we are building all
kinds of different ships in different
products and the re reason for this is
that we can very quickly put together
specialized functional units these are
referred to as intellectual property in
the semiconductor business and then we
can take these and assemble these in
systems on a chip where if we look at
designs today a a chip on the average
has more than 80 of these intellectual
property blocks so these could be for
example a video compressor decompressor
encryption block and so on and each of
these actually is is really a whole
subsystem so each of them in turn is
composed of many more
blocks and equally important is the role
that Eda plays in design optimization uh
that is in reducing part costs in which
in turn help enable new functionality
because things that you wouldn't have
been able to afford or build otherwise
in either dollar cost or they weren't
fast enough they weren't good enough to
do what you wanted to do or they consume
too much power so optimization sort of
pushes this envelope uh pushes this
Frontier such that you can now push this
to include new functionality new parts
that provide new value that you wouldn't
have been able to do otherwise and it is
this part that I think really uh will be
the compelling uh Advantage for Network
design automation that is even though we
don't need it from a pure complexity
point of view but the benefits from
scalability the diversity of different
parts that Parts in this case different
kinds of networks that you could build
and then novel functionality I think
there's enough compelling Advantage here
that if you're looking at Network design
automation this could provide
that um there's also some value in
looking at how Eda has evolved over time
so it started off as just being models
uh so for example things like spice
models which were nothing but equations
that model semiconductor devices then
this very uh quickly as we uh got to
more complex designs uh got replaced by
even specific not replaced but
supplemented by specification mechanisms
like verog which is a hardware design
language but if you look at these
languages they're not not only
specification languages but they have an
underlying model which obviously you
need to understand what is it that these
designs are actually doing the models
were followed very quickly with analysis
and by analysis I mean things like
timing analysis where you can determine
for a given circuit how fast you can
Clock IT functional analysis what
exactly does it do and this really is
the heart of functional
verification once you have models and
Analysis the analysis you can use in an
in a loop for optimization and that's
what what happened and then finally once
you have the ability to optimize you can
go all the way from specification to
optimize designs from these
specifications which is referred to as
synthesis the key point I want to make
here is that these two parts modeling
and Analysis is really the heart that
feeds both optimization and synthesis
and therefore I think if you're going to
imagine a world of network design
automation really have to start from
here and and invest a lot here in
understanding how to do effective
modeling and how to do uh analysis with
for those models for uh enabling Network
design
automation so uh a couple of other
points important points that I wanted to
make here was the first is that you now
if you focus on analysis the analysis
capability impacts design methodology so
to to again go back to this picture here
uh in this picture we can do timing
analysis and functional analysis
separately if I just give you a bunch of
gates and memory elements and ask you
you know how fast does this run what
does it do if I didn't have a
synchronous timing methodology uh where
I could separate the concerns of timing
and function then I really could not be
able to do large designs so the fact
that I can do these separately comes
back and influences and and gets you to
the synchronous design
methodology so this basic idea of
separation of concerns is is really
critical in the sense that it makes life
easier in terms of handling one thing at
a time so again if you look at Network
design methodology so how can we
maximize this how can we do have a
design methodology that lets us deal
with issues separately one at a time
rather than them getting combined into
some horrible you know
multi-dimensional aspect that you have
to handle at a
time now again since the the sessions
about mostly verification uh let's look
at the ability analysis capabilities in
uh having an impact on verification so
this in the hardware Community it's well
known that reasoning about combinational
logic is much easier than reasoning
about sequential loic and as a
consequence this has a direct impact on
how we do designs so in particular going
back to this picture once we fix the
memory locations in the beginning
through the entire design flow that I
showed you actually don't change this
very much and you in fact you don't
change this at all you you obey the
initial uh placement and and the state
definition and as a result the
implementation verification reduces to
combinational logic verification here
which is much simpler so here's an
example of a verification driven design
mind discipline so actually the analysis
capability also impacts your how you how
you verify your verification methodology
so in particular going back to this
point where combinational logic
reasoning is much easier than sequential
logic reasoning uh very often it is very
hard to completely reason about this
complete system so instead what you do
is you look at a time unrolled version
of this combination logic and you you
make claims or you do reasoning about a
fixed number of Cycles which doesn't
give you full verification but it gives
you increased confidence that you know
if a k Cycle System doesn't show you any
bugs then there's a pretty decent chance
that if K is large enough that this
design is free so what I'm going to
do in the remaining five minutes or so
um is show what how this uh last point
that I made about the analysis
capability impacting verification
methodology um this is sort of the
driver of uh our work where we look
where we started looking at network data
planes and said okay so sack based
techniques have had a lot of success in
Hardware verification how do we apply
them in the context of network data
planes so uh in particular what we
wanted to do was we wanted to avoid
State space explosion uh which basically
with the large State space which has
contributions coming from large packet
header size uh the large Network size
with uh thousands of switches tens of
thousands of switches with thousands of
rules and also the state space that
comes because of the concurrency there's
a the packets can get processed at
switches in different orders so this
lead to a large number of packet into
leavings so what we wanted to do was we
wanted to avoid model checking which
deals which basically does um
exploration of the entire State space
and somehow try to see if we can survive
with propositional logic reasoning with
sat and essentially live in the safer NP
complete part of the world rather than
living in the ppace complete part of the
world now one thing that made it easy
for us is that if you look at um the
data plane and especially in the context
of method of of network design like uh
uh software defined networks sdn so what
you can do here is that you can look at
the entire uh Network in at a single
snapshot of it which gives you a static
Network state so the rules and the
switches they're all statically fixed so
that state won't
change um and and there's in the
community this is sort of an accepted uh
sub problem in design verification and
it's Justified because the network State
change is relatively less frequent
compared to the lifetime of a packet
through theet
Network so that takes care of this part
the network switch State we have
essentially um make this a non-issue but
we still have to deal with the packet
header State and the network State due
to
interleavings so what we'd like to do is
we'd like to think of the entire data
plane as a logic circuit so this
combinational logic circuit here with
inputs and outputs and in if you can do
that then essentially these
outputs and even the internal signals so
any of the signals here they're the
functions of only the present value of
input you know we're trying to make the
problem as simple as possible if we can
and if we do this we can then represent
this network as a formula which is a
conjunction of essentially the transfer
functions of all of the switches this
then we can in a standard way uh add to
this a property formula which encodes
the negation of uh what we are trying to
uh prove because if we if if if this
negation never is true then we've found
a counter example so for example to
check the reachability from a point a to
a point B in the netw network uh we can
Define to this network formula that we
just I showed you in the previous slide
we can define a property formula which
is the negation of this and then the
satisfiability of this if it is indeed
satisfiable I have a violation of the
property with a counter example and if
it's unsatisfiable my property holds
okay now that's what we'd like uh but
there are some challenges here uh so in
particular even if I have just limit
myself to a single packet entering the
network a link may see multiple packets
packets so for example I might have a
loop through the network and in this
Loop then the output of this switch will
possibly see multiple packets as they go
through this Loop uh or possibly a
packets from other points in the network
even in the absence of Loops due to
multicasting I might for example have a
packet come here and uh either copies of
this packet go through these two
different paths or modified headers
packets with modified headers go through
these two different paths so the Blue
Link would again see multiple packets so
what we wanted was uh that the switch
outputs be a combinational function of
the inputs but unfortunately we see this
is not the case uh in this case this is
an input output relation and here this
is a fixed Point computation and this is
actually very problematic because what
this means is that you need to store
sets of values and from our experience
in Hardware anytime you need to store
sets of values you know that limits
scalability very
significantly so here's sort of the
adaptation of it that U manages the
situation so if you limit your packet
flow to a single path for a single
package through the network then you can
actually get back our desired property
so what that means is that in the first
picture uh you're going to implicitly
block the loop you're basically saying
I'm not going to allow packet to Loop
and in the multicasting situation what
you're saying is I'm either going to
consider the top path or the bottom path
now that's obviously capturing only part
of the network Behavior you're limiting
Behavior so is this any good you know
what's the point of restricting things
so much that it it really is worthless
so let's go back our goal was counter
examples for property failures uh we
would like to get counter examples that
show failures of these properties so if
we going to limit ourselves to single
packet single path counter examples then
what we'd like to see is what is it that
we can actually check with this so
actually the nice part is that this
suffices for checking functional
properties such as reachability checking
which includes things like wayp pointing
black blacklisting and so on because all
you need to show if a property fails is
one packet as it makes its way through
the network work similarly uh properties
that sort of go across functional and
performance issues things like
forwarding Loops you can actually check
with this so I told you that you you
don't allow forwarding Loops but part of
this methodology actually detects the
forwarding Loop so the way you don't
allow it is by detecting it and blocking
it and then security property such as
slice isolation where uh you you don't
want this is in the virtualization
context where you don't want packets
from one tenant to sneak into the other
tenant so um I think I'm running out of
time here uh so I'll just be very brief
now uh so there are a couple of things
that you can do in the modeling uh to
actually manage this so uh in the
multicasting case essentially what you
do is you non deterministically select
either the top path or the bottom path
through a choice variable and this
Choice variable then gets explored in
the solver to generate all possibilities
for determining the counter example uh
similarly for the um uh loop you do a
little bit of uh just one bit addition
into a packet and and then that one bit
gets modified in some way as it goes
through the network I'll skip the
details but one very important point
that I wanted to make here was that uh
this just one bit addition it avoids
maintaining a full path history because
one of the ways you could check for a
loop is just keep track of all the
switches that the packet has seen and if
you do that you're going to maintain a
whole list of the entire path and this
completely avoids that so the goals that
we had was we never wanted to store any
sets so we are never going to store any
sets so that that goal still still stays
so um you know we we've tested this
empirically so there's one actually very
nice uh uh Benchmark that's available
this is the Stanford backbone Network
this is a real Network significant size
and uh for this network we can detect a
loop in about slightly over 100 seconds
uh forwarding Loop you can detect in
this network and uh this is competitive
with a technique that actually George
has been involved in so this is very
compartive with that and it uses a very
different method it uses stary symbolic
simulation and then to look at
scalability we uh follow sort of the
standard methodology in the verification
Community uh by building some synthetic
networks and um I'll just show some
results here so this is a check for a
forwarding Loop and the sort of main uh
so this this is for uh the two different
methods the SAT based method header
space analysis uh different header sizes
uh for a fixed net number of switches
but uh changing number of routes which
changes the number of rules uh in the
switches so roughly what we see is this
for both meth there's a subexponential
growth for the number of routes and
there's very weak dependence on the
header size and at least for this uh
particular examp this particular
property checking and this class of
benchmarks uh the SAT based method does
better than uh the head of space
analysis and this actually the scaling
continues as we look at larger sizes of
networks uh if you look at reachability
checking actually the roles get switched
heter space analysis does a little bit
better but again we sort of see
subexponential growth with the number of
routes and low dependence on head
size so the last point I'll make here
and maybe I'll just take less than a
minute here because I can see anxiety at
the back here U once you have analysis
you can actually do synthesis and I
won't go through the details but in
particular the fact that you can check
for example the equivalence of two
firewalls using sat based techniques you
can then plug this into a method where
you can build something that's a
symbolic firewall with K rules add some
symbols this is some an idea that sort
of even is used in program synthesis and
then using the same equivalence checking
method what you do is you ask the
question you know is there some symbolic
firewall here that for some assignment
of rules uh some assignment of these
rule symbols can
actually create a firewall that's
identical to the firewall specification
that is there's no difference in the
outputs for these so this translates to
a more complex formulation this is a
Quantified Boolean formula and in
practice this uh tends to not scale very
well uh but the key Point here is that
at least we have based on the analysis
Technique we have a systematic way of
formulating this problem and now we can
devote some attention to actually
building solvers that can help crack
this so this problem by the way shows up
in different forms in software uh
synthesis also okay so I'm going to just
stop here uh I just want to put up the
main points that I put up in terms of
ideas from electronic design automation
that I think we need to have in a
conversation about Network design
automation um design discipline design
flows and abstractions effective
modeling and Analysis maximizing
separation of concerns and in particular
this last point which I touched upon
with the work that we've done that is
how your ability to analyze can go back
and influence how you go about verifying
things okay I'll stop and I don't know I
suspect we don't have time for questions
but I'm happy to take them in the end
thank thank you thank you much
and and uh let's set up um George but uh
in the meantime uh there's could be time
for one or two questions and we should
use the mic for
questions yes uh one one point you made
about like uh what's the driver for
Network design automation might be if
complexity is not growing I think if
even if so a couple things I think but
at the largest end of the spectrum like
Microsoft Google Facebook the complexity
is growing no the complexity is growing
but I don't think it's holding people
back I think people's existing
methodologies are right it's not holding
them back so what really holds so my
point was going to what really holds us
back right now it's not so much the
growing complexity but the agility that
is basically I think the driving force
at least some of the work that we end up
doing is like if the Network's very
complex and hard to reason about then
people are fearful of making change so
unlike Hardware these change requests
for the network they come in all the
time so I think for a lot of the driver
for some of the work we do is like can
you safely change your network which
needs to change every day got it y
that's kind agility is a driver yeah
very valid point
yeah so okay where's the uh switch to
this is forward oh I see okay perfect
thanks again
and
mic so uh the next talk is by the Puppet
Master George uh a dear colleague um who
has uh
um I I work closely with George on on
network
verification um and um he he will Co um
cover the the topic of uh what what he
coins as NDA and uh don't worry you can
talk about it after leaving the room so
all right I'd like to take the next
logical step after shot's talk and try
to see how you might move from the
lessons learned from Eda to what we
might call Network design automation
okay so in order to do that I have to
show you especially if you're not in
networks why reasoning about a network
might be hard so a router is just a box
that Maps add something called prefixes
to Ports so for example that router that
box has two prefixes all destination
address starting with one zero and all
destination address starting with one
and a packet the Box on the left arrives
starting with some set of bits it's
actually a 32-bit IP address but and now
this packet matches both these uh these
rules and the longest match is the first
one so the packet should be shipped out
to Port one on the top so it's so simple
and that's the original internet and it
doesn't really is not very hard to
reason about okay so what comp the many
things have complicated life the first
thing is load balancing okay because
links are running out of gas people
people nowadays don't just send it to
one link they load balance it across a
set of links and most of that is
actually chosen non-deterministically
using some kind of hash function which
is known only in runtime for reasons
that I don't want to talk about they're
horrible but nevertheless okay now the
the the that by itself is okay but then
an additional thing that a lot of people
do I think I better learn heed sher's
lesson and is is that they go ahead and
for security reasons they allow Network
operators to add these manual rules
called Access Control lists or ACLS for
example it's very reasonable given the
slammer worm to be able to block packets
that contain SQL messages right which
are indicated by another field which is
called SQL so the manager might decide
to say on Port P2 block all SQL packets
the difficulty is that it interacts with
load balancing and it's not clear which
set of headers are actually blocked when
they're going to which destination
addresses and it depends on the on the
load balancing function when it switches
as Jeff talk about then stuff changes
again and so it is it is kind of messy
now besides this interaction between
load balancing and and ACI and manual
rules the situation is exacerbated
because we have lots and lots of
forwarding protocols lots of Wenders
with all the syncrasy broadcom orista
and and ultimately it's these manual
things that people have to do to keep
networks working and we only have these
crude tools okay so simple basic
reasonable questions are hard to answer
which packets from a can reach B that's
shed's reachability question can we sort
of isolate students from faculty or at
least the grades and it's it uh and we'd
like to kind of show these kind of
isolation things just like in operating
systems and then when my when your web
server is my my web page is taking too
long to load is the problem the server
or is it the network and this is a
traditional finger pointing exercise and
we also as Microsoft and many other
companies like Google we have a bunch of
data centers linked by by a very
expensive precious backbone Network okay
and we care a great deal about the
utilization of that and we want to know
why these traditional Protocols are
utilizing them poorly we have load
balancers all over the place and
sometimes they don't quite distribute
packets evenly and You' like to kind of
figure this out and ultimately another
horrible thing in our data centers is
mysterious packet losses and we really
really want to know where they are and
why they're occurring so what is what
the world is crying out for is a set of
tools to do bottomup analysis of just
existing systems without waiting for the
Misty future so is there a motivation to
do better yes okay so we know from our
internal networks and I will spare you
the details that we get a lot of Errors
caused by manual stuff and some of them
are externally visible now you might say
oh Microsoft they don't know how to do
anything right but but on the other hand
we've done these surveys and we found
that everybody has this trouble
including Google right they actually
admitted it Matt Welsh is very
Indiscreet and so he admitted it in a
blog which is useful and sherid is
looking for sherid is looking for a
driver right what why now why why why
why didn't we do this 10 years later and
I think one driver besides ril's agility
driver is that we are moving now to the
services market right think us for
example right why would our CEO care we
used to keep office our crown jewels on
disk and we would sell that now
increasingly we're moving it to the
services model so if the network is down
we are going to lose a major fraction of
our Revenue
so suddenly it's an issue that CEOs care
about right it's not a nice to have but
it's a must have all right now that's
networks today but what about tomorrow
as we move to Services it's going to
occur to a lot of CEOs let's optimize
our private Network our data center
Network which is the computer after all
to make it to reduce latency and costs
that wasn't possible till a few years
ago but it's just becoming possible for
example Merchant silicon is available
today cheaply with vendors like broadcom
you can bu build your own router and the
rise of data centers the data center is
like a big computer it's a bunch of
small small computers connected together
by Network you can do what you please
within that Network as long as you you
talk IP to your customers and also
there's software defined networks that
allows you to program these routers okay
so all the opportunity is there but if
we couldn't even design these static
networks in the first place how in the
world are we going to design these new
brand new networks right and so that is
crying out for what's what what shid
said is a design methodology which we
would call which is really going to be
more about designing networks and
synthesizing networks to optimize some
goal okay so those two sort of
intellectual themes I'm going to weave
through this talk and before I do that I
I want to put up this slide which um on
the slide on the left is is something
that my friend Nick mcken sort of first
drove and this analogy he made between
Eda and NDA and uh and I it just starts
with this things like Sher talked about
a standard functional description and it
ends up with layout and finally post
silicon debugging so I want to go a
little further and just wonder what the
corresponding tool chain might be for
networking don't get too hung up in the
details it's just Misty it's a little
mystical it's a vision right but let's
look corresponding to RTL we might need
a policy language corresponding to
things like post silicon validation we
might need debuggers and dynamic
checking and uh and corresponding to
test Benes we need test package
generation and in between we probably
want layers of analysis and layers of
synthesis okay so that's the mo that's
the model and the kind of vision that's
animating a lot of work at MSR right now
so accordingly I want to give you a
flavor of these two strands of work a
little bit of verification which is
mostly about analysis why symbolic
execution and then a little bit about
Automation and a few interesting
problems based on synthesis all right
before we do this okay we have to conf
front this grubby reality that we have
tremendous diversity whether it's a
Cisco box or an Arista switch they're
all so different how in the world is a
tool industry going to be born what
saves us is that in essence there is
something in common okay so we already
know a router it just Maps a bunch of
prefixes to Ports there's another animal
called a bridge doesn't matter what it
is it takes 3 48 bit ethernet addresses
and does an exact match on them and Maps
them to Ports
there's another creature called an MLs
switch that uses small integers called
labels and goes ahead and Maps them to
Ports and sometimes sort of plays with
these labels and now while they all look
different and they all come from
different vendors fundamentally they all
match on some fields and basically do
some actions like rewrite hitters okay
now that's the essential insight for
something called open Flow which you
might have heard of which is a design
movement for future routers but what
we'd like to say is that beside it being
used prospec effectively we can use it
retrospectively to understand existing
networks by mapping them to this
intermediate form to generate tools okay
and so that's the essential Insight
behind uh behind a lot behind this thing
called header space so you start with
this router and it's basically at the
low level that wind surf would say it's
a match and an action and you do this
but you could think of it a little more
abstractly as a header space and the
rule that is matching is a hypercube in
this header space a packet is a point
and what the router is doing is
basically mapping points from one space
to another and uh and and with that what
happens is this the this The Cisco
forwarding table or the bridge spanning
tree table now becomes a set of guarded
commands in classical D St rotation
where one Subspace maps to another and a
sequence like that and if that's the
case and you can compose all these
routers to make a network program the
entire network of boxes and fiber optic
links becomes a big program so now you
should ask as the question why can't we
apply every methodology known to man for
programming debuggers static Checkers uh
runtime Checkers you know specification
mining every idea known in the last 20
years why can't they be applied here and
that's what's exciting us all right so
basically to summarize the head of space
framework it's is going to take all
these routers and summarize them by a
transfer function that Maps sets of
headers to sets of headers so what can
you do with that well now you can do
symbolic execution so imagine you want
the simplest question a talking to B so
what you can do is start with the
complete space at a right which is the
entire possible set of packets and pass
it through the transfer function at at
at the first router and the header space
splits up and you're keeping track of
sets as Sharon said and now you keep
doing that and finally those spaces sort
of move through these transfer functions
and they emerge at B okay and formally
they just a bunch of compositions in
Union
now unfortunately that's not quite
enough because the packet could have
been Rewritten so you need to do one
more step to invert the spaces to figure
out which packets a must have sent so as
long as you have a compositional and
invertible semantics all this stuff can
be done and you can do all kinds of
other things like wayp pointing and
general questions like this so two big
takeaways first remember that from the
point of view of programming languages
and model checking this is just symbolic
execution the real Essence here comes in
the domain specific data structures we
don't just use bdds or throw it into a
model Checker that can give us big wins
second remember it's abstraction we've
taken all these real boxes and written
real Paras into these transfer functions
and now we can stay at this abstract
intermediate form that enables to land
all right similarly the lens that
basically says that we can treat a
network as a program suggests why not
apply the testing lenss people are used
to generating inputs in order to
maximize coverage for testing why not do
the same for networks so we've done this
briefly right and the there's some
differences and nuances first of all
we're not so much into correctness but
we want to test performance how are
links doing are we dropping certain
packets and so the notion of coverage
doesn't become line coverage or function
coverage but covering every link or
every cue or every Rule and we can see
that it becomes better now for those of
you who know about test generation tools
like Dart Patrice is here or CLE what's
different it's much much simpler we
don't have Cycles in normal cases so we
tend to have a finite graph and so we
can throw in very simple set cover so
the intellectual problem is actually
reduced right compared to the standard
problem now when we did Network
verification as shat talked some about
the these answers when we did them for a
single pair we got numbers like a second
but we have hundreds of thousands of
stations and if we start doing that for
all pairs today the numbers
traditionally are about a day
fortunately there is design discipline
in all these modern large networks that
makes life better we tend to design
things according to structures right
just like people design these chips in
very nice systematics we tend to design
them as as these fat trees with backup
routers arranged in certain symmetrical
configurations so for example there's
symmetry in almost a group theoretic
sense where if you interchange these
backup routers life is roughly the same
so it's where a modo so you can kind of
do these quotienting tricks that people
have kind of done before in model
checking but these are based on physical
symmetries not symmetries on The Logical
cryy structure further so Gordon Plotkin
who is one of the world's leading
logicians is visiting uh us and we've
he's worked with us to create this new
semantics that basically has the simple
symmetry theorem that can reduce these
large networks to simple networks with
equivalent uh Behavior proved by
something called B simulation and and
now we can do verification cheaply but
further this design dis displine also
has something like a standard cell you
have these stamps that we put out in
order to deploy our clusters very
frequently and his his sematics also has
a modularity theorem that allows us to
reuse things and parts and and lots of
networks are built this way so we're
kind of excited by using these things
all right so so far I've talked about
data plane verification but there is
this very nice tool has nothing to do
with me but Todd is here Ari is here and
and and rul is here and I don't
understand it well enough so I'm going
to say only three things about it first
of all it's about the control plane
remember that so far I've assumed that
there are these magical forwarding
tables but who built them there's a
routing protocol that's the control
plane there are bugs there too waiting
to happen for example you could have
backup routers with bugs and if you
don't do it right when they come on
they're going to cause trouble so what
these guys have done is actually built
an analysis of that right and there's a
key abstraction they have which
sometimes is sort of not seen they
basically ignore the the the timing
parts or the race conditions they just
model the fix point of the routing
protocol and they look for bugs that
they can find based on that still very
useful Ari is going to demonstrate it
tomorrow morning so if you guys want to
see this in action uh please watch them
okay so I'm going to ignore their tool
chain so sorry guys there it goes all
right there's lots of other works start
starting with Jeff's uh sort of
pioneering work right uh which which
he's going to talk about and ending with
netcat and other stuff U that uh that uh
Nate is going to talk about but I
especially want to mention a lot of work
in uiu on antito and veriflow where
there's a lot of work at UH at uh by by
by by that group all right how am I
doing for
time five minutes all right okay so all
that part rush through was about
analysis okay let's take a deep breath
and wonder what synthesis might be like
okay so it's a bit of a moonshot right
can you imagine telling networking
people in 5 years we're going to
generate all your Cisco config files
from a specification or even better
we're going to generate a specialized
TCP for you from a specification it
sounds crazy but what the heck they're
all professors here so let's shoot for
the moon okay so but I need to move a
little back all right so again the what
we've talked about and what people have
done in this room and others has been
mostly on verification and now we want
to talk about things like synthesis and
maybe
debugging all right Sheron said that one
of the great things about Network about
Eda is it allows you to specialize
things right you have specialized
components we really want to do that sh
we want to do that for our backbone
networks we want to those backbone
networks are so precious we want to
literally pack all the traffic flows
that go in there to maximize their usage
and we we really dislike the traditional
routing protocols that kind of do this
Hit or Miss kind of thing that really
leaves the 30 or 40% on the table okay
so Google's done that we've done that
and so to abstract this problem in a
slightly interesting way there are two
transitions going on here first of all
I'm moving from reachability whether
people can reach to actual quantities
performance second I'm going to move to
problemistic models which is also
interesting okay so to motivate this
problem imagine there is this very
expensive 3 gig link in the middle and
there are four data centers a b c and d
only a is talking to B in this myth
simple example and C is talking to D but
they have a probability distribution a
whenever a sends to B it sends mostly at
1 gabit with 90% probability but
occasionally with 10% probability it
sends at 2 GB now traditionally we like
95% confidence so what a lot of people
do our managers do is they say well in
that case we'll summarize the A to B
traffic as being 2 gbits because that's
what it needs to cross 90% similarly we
do that for the C Tod traffic but in
that case it can't fit in to this little
napsack of 3 gbits per second and we
have to reroute some of the flows
however you will of course have noticed
that the only way you could get to four
is if both A and B send at two with and
if the probabilities are independent
it's 0.1 * 0.1 which is 01 so with 99%
probability if we could analyze the
probability distribution we could pack
the distribution better so this is kind
of an interesting new optimization idea
right and uh it's something that we
began with with with Folks at Berkeley
like like Garth and uh but abstracting
it very simply it sort of suggests a
completely new optimization problem
right so imagine the traditional napsack
problem now instead of pieces you have
distributions and now instead of the
traditional correctness of fit you want
to make sure to pick a subset of the
input distributions such that the
convolution of that subset is less than
some specified failure probability say
it is uh it's 5% and subject to that
correctness spec you want your liveness
spec is performance you want to Max find
the subsets that minimizes the expected
waste or maximizes the average packing
in the in the bandwidth link okay so
this is a very nice problem and it's
sort of I think it's exciting a lot of
people who like so we're working on it
with with a bunch of people including
the carp and Ry uh
RI Kanan and uh so we have some initial
results okay so it is clearly uh you
know at least as as hard as as napsack
and uh it's it's probably a little
harder now there's a ton of other this
is just a flavor of a new area gives you
new optimization problems if you're a
theoretician you should sort of be
excited right so there's a ton of other
synthesis problems you could synthesize
rules right people have done this before
synthesize virtual networks Jeff has
worked on it Sanjay has worked on it you
could synthesize tables with a n and you
could even heaven forbid synthesize A
specialized transport for your own good
and that is kind of a remarkable thought
okay one last slide on debugging that
I'm done okay
so everybody likes I'm a terrible
programmer I love the ability to step
through my program and I'm in trouble I
say what the hell did I do did I you
know and and I love that what is the
equivalent of step and watch for a
network now there have been network
debuggers but they've been kind of batch
debuggers they it's like Bunches of
print F statements and then you kind of
mine them to figure out what's going on
so it turns out that I don't want to
tell you too much more that working with
some really good Hardware designers at
Cisco we kind of have some idea of
something like a a a a step which can
give you the real time sort of fate of a
packet where it went what time it went
in micros seconds right and you have to
do that efficiently without breaking the
hardware pipeline so it's not that
straightforward and uh and it's kind of
kind of like a a a new incarnation of
the old Trace rod with real-time
behavior and how it's done efficiently I
won't tell you just tease you with it so
if you really want to know I'll I'll
tell you the idea later okay it's very
simple all right so I'm ready to wind
out my biggest message for you is that
there is all of these ideas that we have
talked about are old and you must be
wondering can anything new come from
Nazareth right we've seen all this
before we've done symbolic execution
we've done testing I'm done all this
these guys are merely reusing all this
stuff the thing I want to beg you to
reconsider is no everything is in the
domain right the domain has differences
for example in the formulas we have for
networks as shid will talk about we have
limited negation almost no Loops in
practice and uh supposedly as long as
there's no bugs and very small number of
equivalence classes we have even found
it easy to do incremental verification
which is kind of a frontier task in real
verification why because we have a
network graph it has a very specific
structure and it's easy to keep track of
that structure it's kind of you know we
didn't know it was hard and it was
doable test generation if you look at
tools like CLE and they go through all
kind and and and dart or and they go
through Sage they go through all kinds
of effort because they have the state
space is so large they have to use
heuristics to figure out how to maximize
their coverage we can cover the state
space it's not hard because there are no
cycles and finally symmetries right
Gordon's work on
symmetries people have done it before in
model checking but they are doing
symmetry on The Logical structure the
cppy structure we are doing symmetries
because the physical topology is
symmetrical right the backup rers look
identical the and and it turns out again
in the domain as Gordon would always
point out there are differences there
are nuances in the state spaces headers
and locations and those symmetries are
very different from the cisla Emerson
kind of symmetries okay so there's a
whole new world here there's an
intellectual opportunity and we welcome
you to join okay so summarize my points
this is an inflection point right the
rise of services maybe the need for
agility is going to make some of this I
think essential and data centers and
software defined networks are enabling
technologies that make this possible I
think there are ideas here symbolic
execution and Analysis spe spe
specialized to The Domain and
optimization again specialized to The
Domain when so the first one for
analysis the second one for optimization
there's an intellectual opportunity you
get to rethink I have this sort of
somewhat uh dangerous contention that
give me any paper in any interesting
idea in programming languages in the in
the last 10 15 years whether it and and
I think there's a way to kind of
retrofit it with interesting changes
mutus mutas to this new world so it's a
fun thing you know I said you know join
the party but I think there's also a
systems opportunity right there's
working chips today with billions of
gates why not why could we have these
large agile completely easy to reason
about operational networks next and
that's the thing that's exciting us okay
so it's a long shot and who knows will
happen a lifetime but it's something to
aim for thank
you thank you
and
questions
yes
yes 10 years to
uh the correct date on the paper is
actually 10 years in the future from
what you wrote say that again I'll tell
you off okay all right it's from 2004 or
2005 15 yes okay oh the date on the
paper was wrong your paper that's
ratul's
problem I'd like to blame somebody else
yeah I did not quite understand your
comment about about symmetry can you do
you mind repeating what your argument
there was I understand that data center
networks are are symmetric but I I may
have missed that part I went very fast
okay can I tell you it again okay so
roughly speaking we would like to see
that if we interchange two routers right
the beh and you make the right changes
in the headers and the rules right so
you have to give me a we have a Rel a
certain a a certain set of
Transformations we can everything stays
the same the the the questions we want
to for reachability stay the same so
given that right as a setup which we
need to prove we can transform the
original complex fat tree Network into a
thin tree why does that help because we
have less routers and less rules
assuming that verification scales with
the number of components we get speed
UPS of 100x that's what we get okay so
suddenly what used to take Days is now
taking us hours and here you're talking
about data plane verification
specifically we're taking only about
data plane verification but we're
talking about real ones we're talking
about our large data centers so we're
not talking about toy not talking about
Stanford we're not talking about you
know little thing synthesis the real
stuff right and comprehensive all pairs
between every set of predicates done in
and the goal is to do it in a few
minutes and I think we can yes
yes so I'm primarily I guess asking in
terms of um more runtime verification so
one of the things that operators care
about a lot is impending failures right
so that you if you think in terms of um
how the state is getting transformed as
as the traffic is going live something
that's going to fail in the next 30
minutes an hour or so something that
they can essentially track or at least
get ahead up so I'm wondering if you
know all of the you know the first two
talks I heard probably more geared
towards starting verification say let's
check reachability let's check load
balancing which are more static
properties I'm I'm wondering if have you
any thoughts on totally I think that's
part you know I only talked about
debugging but runtime verification a set
of tools is essential I think and things
like yours I think there's been a lot of
work but to put it into this framework
try to try to make it work together with
these other things is important so
totally I didn't mean to ignore it but
there's only 20 minutes okay uh so with
that uh let's uh start the next talk
with Jeff
fromst
school um and uh uh Jeffrey made uh uh
early uh foundational contributions in
network verification and uh he will talk
about abstraction developing Network
verification and design thank you uh
good afternoon uh so today I'm going to
uh look back uh some of the internet
routing research
I performed uh over the last decade and
share with you some of the lessons
learned and observation on leveraging
abstractions for Network verification
and uh design
automation so it all started when I
spent a onee sabatical at CMU I joined a
group led by uh hen and including Dave
malz and Jing xan and I was for forunate
to be involving immediately in a very
interesting project with collaboration
uh with uh with uh several uh AT&T lab
researchers uh Albert Greenberg and
Jennifer Rexford and gizzly Kon uh Tyson
so our goal is to reverse
engineer uh large set of networks
managed by
AT&T uh trying to understand their
routing designs apparently some of
Network counseling experience outages
due to routing anomalies uh folding
loops and uh uh and black holes so we
are given what we have we have the uh
router configuration
files so here is an example of a router
config files for those of you who have
worked with routers you immediately
recognize this and it's not unlike
assembly code and uh so that you it
defines the interfaces for for example
in this very simple example it defines
two interfaces on this router and also
it defines routing protocols run to be
run on this uh uh router so here are the
two routing protocols OPF and bgp and
more
importantly uh there's a lot of policy
defined in this using this very lowlevel
commands so for example uh there's some
packets are being filtered in one of the
interfaces and there are some routes
being shared between the routing
protocols but not every route is shared
only some of routes are shared so this
are all policy decisions that the
operators can apply and that will impact
routing
design so clearly those low information
that's just one router in the networks
we
studied actually some Network have
hundreds of routers imagine all this
files if you do it by manually it's
impossible so that's why we want to
develop a reverse engineering
methodology to automatically extract
routing design from the configuration so
here is example of a uh 900 router
Network and the
files uh the router configur largest Ro
router config files has they're sorted
based on the number of lines in the
config files so you can think the
largest router config has close to 2,000
lines on the average they have more than
100 lines but nowadays some of you
probably already have new data that
shows some of the r configures even
larger than thousands of line can be 10
5,000 lines 5,000 average so that's more
recent data so after some digging so
we're able to develop a reverse
engineering methodology so first we uh
we use uh uh the r configuration files
we're able to infer The Logical IP
typology so this example for example we
can infer there's IP connectivity
between these two uh this this set of
routers and that bit we by mining the
interface information and then we mine
the rout routing protocal configuration
information to uh construct a what we
call a uh routing process graph
so so each router can run one or more
routing process each one corresponding
to a new protocol so most router run one
oops most routers run one
process but some routers like they are
serving as the as a group for multiple
routing domains they can run multiple
routing processes to glue different
routing domain together so in this
example there are two routing domains so
after we construct a routing process
graph we notice that this graph can be
huge right several hundreds of routers
then you have 700s of process at least
so it's not going to be scalable so we
develop a abstraction to make this
methodology scalable we we basically
collapse all the routing process that
share complete ret trility information
that means there's no policy between
them there no Rod filtering between them
we collap them collapse them into one
single roding instance so in this case
we're able to
reduce this routing process graph in
this very simple uh routing instance
graph so by doing so we're able to
extract the large ring structure of the
network
so we apply this methodology to uh
through 30 production networks mostly
median to large size uh Transit and
Enterprise networks so we found a very
interesting uh uh we found that the
designs ring design in the wild are much
more diverse than the textbook model so
what is a textbook model so this is a
textbook model so usually uh the text
model describe a network for company is
as such the company runs a inter interor
Gateway protocol such as OSF or
Isis then the companies use bgp to
connect to each other so this is the
standard textbook model but in the after
we're done uh after we run our uh the
the the tools we we found that most of
networks actually are not conforming to
that model so here is example Network
that uh we we able to uh model so you
can see there are a lot more routing
instance run by this network than just a
single igp not only that a bgp a
traditional interdomain rting protocol
is also sometimes used within Enterprise
used within this network to create a
compartmentalization local
compiz so so the takeway here is that
the netork can have many ring in the
wild can have many R instanes and while
we have very good understanding of
routing protoc at that time we have very
good good understanding ring protocol
such as bgp OPF we do a lot of study on
that to make sure they are are safe but
there are very little understanding at
that time of the interaction of this
routing protocols so in fact the
subsequent uh studies oops they missing
okay here okay so so let the next slides
I want to show you what the mechanism
actually in fact the mechanism governing
this interactions are not defined by the
ETF they were invented by the router
vendors as software patches so the first
routing mechanism is called Rod
redistribution so I want to show you uh
illustrate this uh mechanism using this
very simple example so here there are
two routing domains and B again run two
routing processes to serve as a glue of
the two routing domains to glue the two
routing domain
together so here this the picture shows
the the the rotting process running by
run by router B and uh when a route is
advertised from the left domain which is
RI domain by
default the the router in a in in a
different domain the OSF domain will not
be able to see that rout advertisement
in other words the two uh two networks
are SE separated okay so so by
configuring rou distribution
you can you can address this problem by
configuring r r Distribution on router B
so this is router distribution using
this command so this is a configuration
command that enable route RK uh
distribution by using this R
distribution the routes from the rip
domain will be injected into
the uh uh OPF now the two host on the
two networks can communicate with each
other
and uh the second mechanism is called
rout selection now why is rout selection
required because as as we're seeing that
some routers run multiple routing
processes so they will offer multiple
routes were offered by different routing
protocols how do you select a route
between these routing protocols because
different routing protocols use
different types of metrics rip use hop
count ORF use a integer cost function so
r selection is required when you have
routes coming from two different
protocols again router
vendors introduce this as a rout as a
software patch they basic introduce a
universal metric called administrative
distance to arbitrate between rout for
arbitrate between routes from different
routing
protocols so let me show you this
example so in this case D another router
that run multiple routing processes will
receive two routes one come on the rip
uh uh R instance and by default it has a
administrative distance of 120 and uh
OSF will receive a redistributed route
uh from the rouer B which has an
administrative distance of 110 so since
110 is smaller than 120 so this in this
case the router will install the the
oppr route so the the operator can over
that default ad value by using a simple
command called distance 90 in this case
it will make rip routes more preferred
to the OPF routes so these are the two
mechanisms uh uh used nowadays
for router to exchange routes between
routing protocols and the subsequent
study have
confirmed that the these two mechanisms
have Major Impact rounding safety and uh
I want to also say something about uh uh
sdn so sdn by
centralized uh by logically centralizing
the control
plane uh eliminates some of the problems
associated with distributed roding
protocols however is still uh uh you
still have this issue of multiple
control functions competing for the
forwarding path so so so recent work has
shown that this kind of problem can
still occur
the conflicts between multiple control
functions and then the the problems can
be even more complicated in a hybrid
networks when the network is partially
migrated to sdn so now you have to deal
with both distribut ring protocols and a
centralized control
plan so uh we with the uh the the the
after we done the revers engineering
work will we move on to a core question
in network verification reability
basically we post the question can we
mine sufficient
information from the configuration files
in order to predict reability when and
and whether or when two hostes can
communicate so the state of at that time
was
build it and test it basically
leveraging the uh the probing tools such
as ping and trace
route so the discount of poping tools
have major shortcomings as I will
illustrate with this simple example so
this Enterprise
has two sales offices and there certain
accounting
machines are only allowed to communicate
with a server
in the in in the central office so so
here is so the the the common practice
is that install a packet filter on the
links to implement this very simple
policy now what if
the netor designer want to add some
resilience Okay add some resilience and
uh so in this case he want these two
links are deployed and they config the
routing p to to use the links when the
primary links fail okay so a common
practice in with in the network
Community is that in the operation is
that to use template driven
configuration basically copy existing
configuration to the new links so in
this case he will copy the packet
fatures from the existing link to to the
to the new
links so everything works great because
testing will not find any problem
because when there no link failure
package still Traverse the primary links
everything works but when the actual
failure happens the packet will Traverse
the backup links there's
issue because the you can see this link
doesn't allow packet from B to to to go
through this link and packet will be
dropped so so how do we solve this
problem and uh so we're able to uh we
after some digging we are able to we're
able to find this abstraction called the
r ility set to model the reability
requirements basically reability set is
a set of all packets permitted from one
network location to another Network
location so it's naturally a packet
filter or Access Control list can be
modeled as a uh uh by a reability set so
for example permit AC is just a simple
predicate to find all the packets
meeting that practic
Kate the you factor routing protocols
can be added as a set can be added as a
dynamic destination address based packet
filter because if a packet does not
allowed to route to the next node it
will be treated as a reject rule if it's
allowed then it's permit so here by
simply using a intersection function we
can model the behavior of routing
protocols how many
minutes the package transformation also
can be uh model as a generalized uh uh
conversion
functions so by by by doing that unified
modeling we're able to create a what
call the reability analysis graph so
each Ed so each Edge just associate with
one compound composite filter taking
effect all the packet filter configured
on interfaces and routing protocal
effects and packet transformation
gateways so by doing that we're able to
infer reability
along a path for example yourability for
along this path will be set intersection
of the two
filters we are able to also uh uh
compute the the the the the reability
sets uh among multiple path by you
simply using the set Union operation so
so let's go back to the old example so
you can see that with the S with the
reability computation uh model we we
developed you're able to the operator
without deploying the new configuration
can make this uh can do this derivation
and the operator will find out the the
the reability from B to C will be
affected by this without be correct
because the reability set will become
empty that will indicating there's a
reability problem and then the co simple
copying of filter rules would not be
sufficient okay so how many minutes do
IUS one minus one
okay so I'll wrap up so so the work has
since have been generalized in several
ways the the most
not uh The Bullying certifi certifi
ability formulation in 2011 had space
analysis George and others in 2012 and
also more recent work that uh a a group
in University of Texas at Austin develop
very fast algorithms uh to do uh
reability analysis they're able to uh
check reability for most networks under
minute okay so I guess I'm going to skip
some of the
slides and so we also appli the the the
uh the similar abstraction to uh design
we call the call synthesis and uh so
we're able to this is the work we're
jointly done but with San Ralph and uh
so we're able to use the reability
reability set abstraction were able to
automatically create package filter
placement
algorithms uh so that given a set of uh
given set of reability requirements
which model as a reability matrix were
able to automatically create uh
determine where which interface plac the
packet futters and what type of packet
fter to be placed all right so to wrap
it
up so I I I think with the the following
observations that I still think there's
a huge magic Gap exists between network
service objectives and the actions of
individual uh protocols and uh and the
nodes so software defined networks
clearly Elevate the ab the level of
abstractions but on the other hand they
also introduce a new type of nodes and
still allow diverse control application
to impact the the forwarding plan
simultaneously and so that that has
create a a still the sematic Gap Still
Remains so I argue that we need some
higher level higher level abstraction to
contain this what I call curse of Min
knobs as we need to make sure that the
design space is constrained so that uh
the design can be uh carry
out all right thank thank thank you very
much so uh please ask questions while we
set up we are running a little bit short
of time but uh Nate's is to speak very
fast I just wanted to say that I think
many years ago like 10 years ago when
this was not fashionable Jeff and uh who
and all the gang at CMU including Dave
Ms our own Dave Ms worked on this so so
it all started uh with with this kind of
work
so it's in the folder
it
is I have the
clicker is it it
is here
R can you help us get the PDF
up
okay great so uh I've been asked to take
my carefully tuned 22-minute talk and
deliver it in four minutes so I
apologize for if I skip some slides or
talk like an Auctioneer I guess this is
a proof that uh you know the
probabalistic napsack problem is hard
and reasoning about quantitative
properties is hard um so I want to talk
about some work we've been doing on uh
sort of taking programming language
techniques and trying to apply them to
networks uh this is completely in line
with all the talks we've seen and really
Builds on a lot of these seminal efforts
like like Jeff's from uh from a long
time ago um so we've seen that networks
are important and getting big and hard
to manage and yet uh somehow Network
operators seem to do things well um they
have you know a bunch of really cunning
tricks that they use and and for the
most part networks uh are pretty
reliable and and uh and sort of run well
and I think R put his finger on it when
he said you know the problem is not
getting them to work it's that they're
really not very agile uh you know
there's kind of this crazy bag of tricks
that are used uh to generate
configurations to do monitoring and to
debug faults um and so people get kind
of conservative and it's hard to think
about making big changes in networks and
so what I want to Advocate is that you
know if we want to move to this vision
of kind of an NDA uh world that we need
to find some of these abstractions that
shab was talking about you know
compositional programming units that we
can sort of uh work with an isolation
make them do something complicated plug
them into a bigger system and uh and
have everything work and so um we've
been sort of trying to do this uh using
program languages as the vehicle for
developing these abstractions um and so
our basic methodology is you know try to
design some languages try to study their
semantics often from many different
perspectives so looking at logical
semantics or operational semantics uh
and then build tools that that leverage
those semantics to uh to do useful
tasks um and like the other talks I'm
going to focus not on quantitative
properties but on just reachability
properties um unlike some of the other
talks uh instead of looking at sort of
machine models I'm going to focus on um
what I'm going to call programming
models uh so the difference here is that
instead of kind of thinking directly
about things like you know pipelines of
Hardware forwarding tables I'm going to
just from the start think about
mathematical functions on packets and so
that's what what I'll be working with um
and if you kind of Start From First
principles and this is very much not the
way that we discovered uh the system to
show you but it's kind of an interactive
way to to tell the story um there's kind
of two things that a network does it has
to classify packets so you have these
big tables that have rules and their job
is to sort of separate all the incoming
packets into different bins and then
those packets get forwarded along
different paths through the network and
if you take these two key features
classification and forwarding and you
try to design a little programming
language that would do both those things
I think you end up with something like
this this netcat language and basically
what it is is a Boolean algebra which
just gives you a way to describe
predicates smashed together with a
cleany algebra or a little language of
regular Expressions which describe paths
plus a couple of Primitives for
describing how packets get modified and
moved through the network and so this
combination of these two uh Boolean and
clean the algebras has been studied
before my colleague Dexter coen's been
working on the system for about 20 years
um and when you put them together and
interpret them as operating on on sets
of packets uh you get this new system uh
that we started looking at a couple
years
ago um and this is a core language so
it's really not trying to you know
handle Cisco iOS U but you can encode
lots of other things on top of it so
it's really trying to distill you know
down to the essence sort of the basics
of these packet processing functions and
how they compose and and work together
so conditionals for example can be
desugared into a slightly more
complicated
program um these things all describe
functions I won't take you through this
but here's a picture of sort of how um
the path concatenation or sequential
composition operator works so packets
come in they get run through the first
part of the program that generates a set
of output packets and then those get
pipe through the second program and then
you get a bigger set of output packets
um and the other operators are all
similar
so losing the bottom of my slides uh so
in addition to CR my talk into a small
number of minutes you get to see 80% of
my slides
actually I think we just have
a one problem okay so um one of the neat
things about this language is you can
use it for programming and I'll tell you
about that but you can also use it to do
the kind of verification we've seen in
Jeff's work and in header space uh and
and other Frameworks um so one thing
that you can do is you can basically
take these Hardware tables and you can
just treat them as programs as George
said and those are just programs in our
language you can also take the structure
of the network uh so all the links in
the topology and you can represent those
as a different program um and then you
can kind of take these things together
and you can actually model mod in the
language the iterated processing that's
done by a network along any number of
steps uh so you can kind of start with
the program that just does the
processing by all of the devices I call
that policy then you can look at uh
processing that happens with policy with
topology in the middle then policy again
that's the second term and if you take
the limit of this you get the term on
the bottom where we have any number of
policy topology uh interleaf steps and
so this gives us a way to model the
reachability uh behavior of a network as
a term in our language and and once
we've done this uh we can start to do
verification uh by reducing questions of
Interest into equivalence problems so
this is kind of a very you know well
understood approach in verification
where if you have an expressive
formalism that can serve both as
specifications and as implementations
and you can decide equivalence uh you
can play the verification game by uh
doing various constructions and then
checking equivalents so to do things
like check reachability um in this case
I want to ask the question you know does
the network forward all packets received
at some Ingress to the egress
I can construct my network model that
term on the left and prefix it and
suffix it by the Ingress and egress and
then just ask is this thing the same as
a program that just forwards directly
from somehow teleporting packets from
Ingress to ESS and if that's true then
it does the required function if not
then then uh it doesn't and lots of
other properties like Access Control
policies isolation Loop Freedom black
hole Freedom can all be reduced in this
way the cool thing about doing this from
a from the perspective of a programming
language is um we don't need to
necessarily design Uh custom new
decision procedures uh in order to solve
these verification problems so we can
actually study using the schematics of
the language um what equivalence means
and in the case of necat there's
actually a complete custom deductive
system uh this little proof system
characterized by these few dozen axioms
uh that Capt that completely capture
equivalents um so I won't step through
these we would be here till 3 p.m. um
but these capture sort of natural things
like the concatenation operator is
associative distributes over Union the
way you'd expect and for the packet
operation
modifications and test a packet sort of
behave the way you'd expect so modifying
and then testing a packet the same as
just modifying it two modifications in a
row the second one cobers the first and
so on and so forth and the remarkable
thing about having this little domain
specific language is that this this
axium system the few dozen that I showed
you is actually both sound and complete
so it's sound meaning anything we can
prove is equivalent using these axioms
actually describes equivalent functions
and more remarkably any two equivalent
functions we can write in the language
using you know the all the features of
the language um there is a proof using
these axioms that they're the same and
so this gives us a way to uh to do
verification uh in a perhaps simpler
system than maybe you know shipping
things off to a
solver um another nice thing about
having a language like this is that we
can actually exploit some of the
mathematical structure that it's built
on and in this case necat has uh a sort
of automa autom Bones and so we can
actually come up with a sort of
generalization of the kinds of
constructions you probably learned about
in uh in undergrad Cs and actually build
finite state automa that are completely
equivalent to the netc cap programs that
we started with and then we can use that
as a slightly more practical way to
decide equivalence um so last year we
built a tool that does this uh these
automa are a little more complicated
than standard automa uh because of the
states of packets and the way that
modifications and tests interact um but
uh you can do this and then you can
decide equivalence by building automa
and then comparing the graph structure
of those automa using a notion of B
simulation that that George talked about
and the performance is actually
competitive with tools like header space
and and others um here are some simple
results that I won't go into but they're
benchmarks synthetic benchmarks that
show the scalability on real world
topologies for uh properties like
connectivity Loop freedom and also
checking equivalence of programs that
were generated by a
compiler um so this thing actually can
be made to scale reasonably
well um in addition uh you can use this
language for verification you can also
use it for programming so uh in the
spirit of what shirro was talking about
you know if we want to start to take
some of these building blocks and sort
of uh idiomatically structure them into
templates and start to implement various
forms of functionality uh that can be
sort of replicated and and verified
modularly um I think a language like
necap provides a nice starting point for
that kind of thing and we' started to
explore some of these richer
constructions so looking at things like
how could we synthesize and generate
virtual networks and that can all be
done within the context of netcat how
can we do things like add a notion of uh
bandwidth and start to reason about
traffic engineering we started to do
that things like fault tolerance and so
on so having this really nice clean
elegant lean automat based model behind
your language means it's very robust and
if you want to try and add new features
you have a sort of set of guidelines uh
that you can use to to sort of uh to
kind of push that investigation forward
and so having this structure uh can be
very
valuable so um in the last couple
minutes I want to talk about some other
things you can do when you have this
kind of linguistic model and that is
namely connect it to real
implementations and also uh use
synthesis to generate some of the lowl
tools you would need to run these things
in a real Network um so if you're in the
business of using a language like netcat
uh not just for verification but for
programming you might wonder if uh the
compiler that's mapping from the high
level language down to the
implementation could get things wrong
and so one way you can convince yourself
that this is that this is not going to
be a concern is by actually building the
compiler uh in a proof assistant um this
is something that's sort of been a Grand
Vision Tony has a famous paper
where he basically said building
verified compilers is something we
should be doing um and it's it's become
quite practical in recent years because
the proof assistance and automation has
gotten very good um so a couple years
ago we built a verified version of a
precursor to net called net cor where we
actually formalized things like the
language all these forwarding tables the
topology and we formalized a very
low-level Machine model called OpenFlow
all in a proof assistant and then proof
theorem showing that our compiler and a
runtime system that deals with Dynamic
changes as the state of the switches is
being modified that all of this
correctly implements our nice clean
functional semantics of the program so
when you have a kind of nice clean
language model you can actually you know
not uh not have to sort of Hope and prey
when you run these things you can
actually connect them uh in code and
prove and prove very rigorously that the
implementations are going to do what you
expect um I'm going to skip over this
just in the interest of
time okay um something else you can do
when you have this kind of language
model is you can start to use it to deal
with Dynamic networks as well um so one
problem that comes up often in in
networks is that you have to somehow
change the program or the policy that
you're running and so you're in the
situation where you have the network
configured one way and you want to
reconfigure it to some other uh to some
other state maybe uh your security
policy has changed maybe you want to
take some devices down for maintenance
and so you have this problem of how do
you get from uh one configuration to
another and this is hard because in
general you can't you know take down the
network for maintenance and you also
can't sort of update all the devices
instantaneously so you have to step the
network through a series of intermediate
configurations uh that are neither the
initial program nor the final program
and somehow this has to behave well um
if you do this in undisciplined ways you
can easily end up breaking all the
properties that you were so careful to
verify um and so uh we did some work a
few years ago where we said well maybe
we should design update mechanisms where
we can get guarantees that although the
network will be stepping through these
intermediate configurations they'll
still preserve some of the properties of
the configurations that we started with
and so we proposed this notion of a
consistent update um sometimes also
called packet coherence um where every
packet or set of packets that going
that's going through the network is
going to be processed as if the network
was in one of these static
configurations so the network may be
going from red to blue to green to
purple but any single packet is going to
be processed completely as if it's just
in one of those States um semantically
this is really nice because it means if
you've done verification all those
verification properties get lifted from
static networks to Dynamic networks
automatically um and there's also many
different ways to implement this um and
some folks in MSR led by rul and and
collaborators uh and other groups have
developed uh many different ways of
actually providing these kinds of
consistency properties
um one thing that I'm especially excited
about and working on recently is on uh
doing what we call update synthesis so
uh if you want to have these kinds of
guarantees that persist across Dynamic
changes um one way is to use a very
general technique like some kind of
two-phase protocol to implement the
update but that's expensive and wastes a
lot of memory and so if instead you know
a specific set of properties that you
want to be preserved across the update
then you can actually use ideas from
program synthesis to to find uh update
programs that get you from the initial
program to the final program program
automatically and so we recently built a
tool where we feed in a property we care
about maybe Loop freedom and
connectivity and then we search through
the space of possible updates here I'm
indicating updated nodes in blue until
we find a sequence that gets us from the
initial program to the updated program
while never violating the property and
there's a bunch of kind of as George
said you know you can kind of take
things off the shelf from the synthesis
literature and start applying those
techniques uh to this problem in
networking and get tools that perform
quite well okay so I'm going to stop
there and uh I think this is a great
session thank you to Nikolai and rul and
and George for organizing um I think uh
this is a really exciting time uh
there's kind of multiple points of
inflection that are sort of uh we're
experiencing right now and I think this
idea of having uh a mathematical basis a
programming basis for building and
managing networks is exciting um and I
hope some of you will will join the
party all right
Victor so I have two
questions we can skip the Applause in
the time
the the first question is can you do the
reverse can you take have you tried to
take configuration files spse them out
and create the language create the
program from it um so yeah we that's the
kind of embedding I was talking about is
going from so you've done that in our
case we take OpenFlow config so we're
not taking Cisco iOS but we're taking
open Flow forwarding tables and
reembedding those as neat terms how hard
would it be to take something that is
not open Flow at this point well I think
lots of people in the room have done
that um and also some people at Brown
have looked into that um so if you're
just talking about getting a static
snapshot then it's pretty
straightforward it's basically a parsing
problem if you're talking about uh you
know actually handing the Dynamics of
real routers and their control planes
that there's a that's a hard problem
okay so that's fine that was just a
simple clarification so the question I
really have is so are we done now with
this I mean it's I'm I'm listening to
your talk and I'm thinking okay so he
has a language model which can be very
things can be verified and so I'm trying
to
figure what's so I think the the place I
would say where there's a lot of
excitement right now which conveniently
is on my slide um I started from this
very simple model of networks as
functions and only looking at
reachability properties and those are
two huge assumptions that are you know
there's a huge Gulf between that and
what people are doing in practice um so
one thing that we're looking at right
now that I'm excited about is
probabilistic semantics so exactly as in
George's napsack problem you know
typically you know
what kind of traffic will appear at your
network and if you want to reason about
congestion properties um even though you
don't have perfect knowledge of exactly
what pack is going to arrive at the
Ingress you'd like to be able to make
predictions about how much congestion
you're likely to see and so um again the
advantage of having this kind of nice
language models you can start to make
the language probalistic instead of just
being deterministic and there's a nice
sort of design recipe for doing that so
that's one area I think is exciting um
another huge area is is adding State um
I know there's work at mssr and by lots
of other groups that's looking at um if
you want to move away from this model of
networks as pure functions and you want
to handle things like middle boxes uh
that have arbitrary you know hundreds of
thousands of Lin C programs that are
running inside of them maintaining State
and doing different things to packets
based on their internal State well this
doesn't handle any of that um I think
the the sort of methodology should
extend but you're in the kind of hard
case of General software verification at
that point um and then another
interesting uh area that I know some UIC
folks and us are looking at is um what
about properties that don't just concern
a single packet what happens to it but
possibly multiple packets and how they
might coordinate with each
other okay
thanks right so with that with excellent
talk thank you very much for attending
the
session